DeSantis May genuinely not want this
ugly primary against Trump Trump's not
going to run in 2028 no matter what
either he'll have been president for
four more years and that'll be it or
he'll lose and he'll be 82 or however
old he would be then and he's not going
to run then the way to do it would be
for DeSantis to politely bow out or does
not run and then be ready to go in 2028
DeSantis would be like 48 years old at
the time and that might be the absolute
best way to go it's an interesting idea
it is a quite an interesting idea I just
don't know if DeSantis is going to be
able to get away from the polling
numbers that he has despite the fact
that he has he's not even running yet